s'il vous plaît oui
une grande frite à coca c'est un
antiseptique pour la peau ça d'accord là
je vais vous donner quelque chose
d'aussi bien
voilà ça m'a un aérosol qui est aussi
bien opéré
c'est tout ce que vous voulez
regarder ça et le cycle pour chien et
c'est bon pour le chien c'est bon aussi
pour vous quand vous sortez en boîte
quand vous attrapez une gamine
vous mettez une capote toujours d'accord
pourquoi vous me dites parce que sinon
c'est trop dangereux et moi après je
serai pas tranquille je vais vous
imaginer sortir et tout attraper
gonzesse et puis pas mettre de capote
d'accord donc je veux bien vous soigner
les yeux mais d'abord il faut faire
attention
si la prévention contre le sirop
alors donc je suis pas venu pour ça tu
sais Monsieur mais moi je préfère
tranquille sinon vous êtes ce qu'il vous
faut en préservatif
[Musique]
alors c'est efficace 5 mois contre les
puces 4 mois contre les tiques il doit
être porté en permanence donc à la
crèche vous lui laissez un et si vous
voyez que votre enfant va secoue à la
crèche
voilà
s'il te plaît
[Musique]